bonjour ma très chère amy je vous
dérange vous semblez bien affairé vous
pouvez dire monsieur 10 nov enfin il
faut dire que je range manquer ce que de
temps en temps ça commente aline jura tu
va pour le mieux chez rami d'ailleurs je
me fais que passer vous savez que c'est
ce soir que commence la kermesse dans la
salle des fêtes
c'est vrai j'avais complètement oublié
oui ça lui jure bonjour monsieur du sne
abaca labiale informe toi au moins
bonjour enfin casimir bons joueurs de
quoi parlez vous eh bien monsieur du
cela me rappelait que la fête qui a lieu
à la salle des fêtes débutent ce soir
oui je suis tout désigné étant donné mon
titre de président de la fed des 2 en
temps pour prendre en main le choix des
lots pour la super tombola qui aura lieu
à la fin de la fête et kelly vous offrir
moins chers amis je ne peux rien vous
dire pour l'instant mais croyez-moi ça
tout à fait original aller mais attendez
attendez
est ce que je pourrai vous aider
benghazi n'était pas une bonne volonté
mais vois-tu dans ce cas très précis
faut de l'originalité de l'expérience du
goût du raffinement
oui casimir de l'originalité du manque
d'originalité enfin bon je voulais faire
a mis un but à leur voix à celle du snap
est bien souvent casimir tu n'as pas eu
beaucoup de succès au mans en revanche
city si tu voulais bien m'aider à
déblayer moukassa je veux bien je
reviens qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
bien écoute prend les affaires que je
vais te tendre les raisons d'un gros tas
d'accord c'est julie j'ai jamais compris
comment tu arrivé avec autant de choses
dans un si petit kiosque et bien sans
doute parce que c'est à quelqu un peu
magique par un père tomasik on aura tout
vu
mais pourquoi veux-tu ajouté toussaint
un bien parce que ça m'encombrer
personne n'en veut tiens par exemple ces
noyaux là c'est pour les fonds de tarte
mais ça ne me sert plus à rien puis gde
là qu'on a qu'on a pas pour les enfants
ya quelques temps et ils ne sont plus
bons oui mais enfin c'est pas une raison
pour qu'on vote écoute saison ce que tu
veux mais tu es barre en sport tout en
privant d'accord oulala je n'ai pas
vouloir passer mon dieu le bateau est
arrivé
casimir garde-moi mon kiosque juste le
temps d'aller au port bon d'accord mais
des pêches coin oui promis oh la la la
la la qu'est-ce que je sais ce que je
vais bien pouvoir faire de tous ces
vieux truc françois tombe bien moi julie
voudrait se débarrasser de toute cette
vieille chose ah tu veux pas les emmener
ne coûte casimir si julita demander un
service
il faut pas t'en débarrasser sur
quelqu'un d'autre excuse moi je peux pas
je suis en train d'écrire une très belle
histoire va se revoir c'est rapide je me
suis mal pris qu'est ce que je devais
faire de tout ce à quoi je vois monsieur
du snav je vais essayer une autre
méthode
monsieur disent non ne partez pas j'ai
pour vous quelque chose de très
intéressant rené par là je lis m'a
confié des objets très rare pour votre
tombola avait envoyé en voyant ça tout
de suite wyeomyia 10 oiseaux de 10 watts
aux rares tentatives montre moi ça des
bécassines de bavière puis des
et des mois de désaccord voilà les bleus
les mouettes des açores ce à son bord 1
enfin casimir je veux pas me procurer
des oeufs
enfin monsieur l'isna vous n'avez pas
acheté des oiseaux tout fait dans une
cage comme tout le monde c'est banal cce
sont prêts à éclore
alors voulez poser délicatement sur un
édredon vous asseyez dessus pendant
quelques jours bien au chaud et vous
aurez des oiseaux splendide ah ah bon tu
as peut être raison
ouais et j'ai également des cerisiers
engrais mon enfant qu as tu mis hors jeu
je n'ai pas la carotte d'un déménagement
veux tu que je transporte des cerisiers
pas de problème là j'en ai 45 sous un
très petit volume en 45 cerisier
engraisser pas formidable attendez j'ai
également un gilet regarder un
magnifique gilet sans manche les
bourrins alors si vous préférez un gilet
à manches - vous prenez ce manche à
balai ouais vous enfilez vous me suivez
un exemple filer le sait dessus voilà et
ça fait un gilet à manches à ça alors
que les miens je suis étonné que tu
trouvais ça tout seul parce que c'est
tout à fait originale
je ne sais pas si tu te rends compte
mais si j'expose ça à la tombola
gendarmes ce succès considérable car ce
sont de vrais petits chez giuly a
vraiment bien fait de me confier toutes
ces choses là pour vous un regret a dit
mir tu es un génie
je ne vous ai pas montré le plus beau à
c'est un paragrêle un paragrêle voilà
c'est pour se protéger de la grêle
ah oui c'est un object rey a évidemment
celui ci n'est plus tout à fait neuf à
oui mais il tend encore servir la
dernière fois les les grêlons leur un
peu troué m'enfin ça ira quand même hein
casimir je suis véritablement sans voix
mais je n'ai pas besoin de votre voix
monsieur du snob vos bras suffiront mes
bras oui parce que tous ces objets sont
à bout
à condition que vous les ans portier
tout de suite
ah ah ah bon ben oui voilà voilà
oui et tu ne peux pas mais d un petit
peu par hasard ou alors là je regrette
monsieur du slam et julie mas m'a chargé
de garder son kiosque
alors monsieur du snop comme ces gens
qui a vous de me débarrasser
que dites-vous m'a charmé c'est moi qui
suis enchanté que concours y ait pensé à
moi je suis très touché aimez vous allez
vous
non je vais les exposer tout de suite à
l'accueil est encore cher ami casimir
c'est un vrai coup j'avais demandé de me
débarrasser de ces vieilleries pas de
les jeunes et à monsieur du snam enfin
jury monsieur jean en est ravi d'avoir
tous ces objets 1
six jeunes avaient jeté sans été du
gaspillage duvoid judy moi je me demande
si pour une fois
casimir n'aurait pas raison
[Musique]